Welcome back. I'm Alex Lyon. This is lesson 3 of 7 in the course. In this lesson
I want to give a little warning, a little
heads up. A lot of people give pushback
on this particular strategy that you're
going to see where I talk about using
plain English, plain language to express
yourself. It's one of the most valuable
ways to make your messages more clear,
more concise, and more confident and yet
some people resist. They want to keep in
the sophisticated, complicated language.
So, if you feel that you're in that crowd,
if you're one of those people that
doesn't want to do that, then check
your self talk. Figure out what it is
that's going on in your mind and address
it because, again, all the tips in the
world are not going to change the way
you ultimately communicate unless you
figure out what's happening internally
that's driving your communication. So
let's jump right in.
In our last lesson we looked at how to
form a concise overall message. In lesson
three, will look at concise
sentences. Concise tip number three is
use short sentences. Oliver Wendell
Holmes, a well-known judge from about a
hundred years ago, said, "Speak clearly if
you speak at all; carved every word
before you let it fall." It's a very poetic
way to say, you want to work on short
sentences and express yourself concisely. Short sentences pop. They sound much more
confident, more concrete, and much more
memorable than long-winded sentences.
They sound like news headlines, topic
sentences in paragraphs, items in a
bulleted list, and one line jokes. A lot
of times people will develop a nice
clean, crisp way of communicating and it
sounds much more confident than
long-winded demanding sentences. So, you want to use as few words as possible.
Strategy number one. Shave words. Comedian Jerry Seinfeld talks about how longer
jokes are very hard to make funny and
their much funnier when you shorten
the jokes and make them pop. He was
talking about the length of jokes and he
said, "If it's too long, just a split second
too long, you will shave letters off of
words. You count syllables to get it just
right. It's more like songwriting." When he
says songwriting he is referring to how
songwriters have to fit
their words into certain beats. And
they will have to come up with creative
ways to express themselves in very few
words. So Seinfeld has a joke about Pop-
Tarts where he really practices what he
preaches. He says about Pop-Tarts, "They
can't go stale cause they were never
fresh." Which is hilarious. But it's
amazing how we can communicate that and in so few words. And there's not a single
extra letter in this punch line. They
can't go stale cause they were never
fresh. He doesn't say they will never go
stale or they can never go stale. That
would be too many words. You can't go
stale cause instead of because they
were never fresh. There's not, I can't
think of anything that I would shave off
of this and it's much funnier because of
it.
The lesson here is you want to get rid
of the clutter so your sentences sound
more concise and more confident.
So, which sentence sticks with you. Look
at two samples about voting. "If you are
bored and disgusted by politics and
don't bother to vote, you're in effect
voting for the entrenched establishments
of the two major parties, who please, rest
assured are not dumb and who are
keenly aware that is in their interests
to keep you disgusted and bored and
cynical and to give you every possible
reason to stay at home doing one hitters
and watching MTV on primary day." That's a
very long sentence. It's going to be difficult to remember what the message is here.
Here's B "if you don't vote you don't
matter." Which was said by Sean Penn in a
movie about a politician from the South.
If you're asking me which line sticks? If
you don't vote you don't matter stuck
with me for years after I saw that movie
one time. Now, I don't know if the
politician he was playing actually said
that or if the people who wrote the
movie just crafted it. But it's a
well-crafted sentence and again there's
not a single extra letter or word in
that sentence. That's why it sound so
confident, whether you agree or disagree
with the sentiment, it sounds confident and
it really pops. So, let's shave the
clutter to make this sound like a
headline. A few things came up,
complications I guess you could call
them, that are going to cause some
unforeseen delays and I'm not sure if we can get it
all done by Wednesday--now we might--I'm just saying that we're going to have to
see what happens and play it by ear.
How could we shave this clutter to make
it sound much more like a news headline?
If it were me, I would do it this way. I'm not sure we get all done by Wednesday. Now we
might. You could even reword it slightly
I'm not sure we can get it all done by Wednesday
because of delays.
Is there anything else we could shave
from the sentence? Shave a few more words
like Seinfeld? What would he do? I think
probably would take the extra few words
out that he could and that would make it
sound even more concise and confident.
Let's try another one. Let's shave the
clutter. What do you recommend we do when
we visit Rhode Island?
Well, let's see. I'd say probably the most
amazing place, I mean it's really amazing
as long as the weather is good, is the
beach in Rhode Island, because that's what
we're known for and it's not called the
Ocean State for no reason.
So, this is a pretty long answer for a
very short question. What do you
recommend we do? And if it were me, I
would shorten this all the way down to
get rid of almost everything and I would
say, The most amazing place is the beach.
Can we shave this even further? Well we
might be able to but you don't want to
overcorrect and shave it down to single
words. I think if you ask them this
question and they answered, the beach, they might sound a little too clipped and
little dismissive. So you make sure you
form full thoughts, full sentences and
you're going to be on safe ground.
Strategy number two. Use plain English. A
lot of people perhaps to sound smart,
perhaps because they love language, will
dress up what they say in unnecessarily
complicated vocabulary. So you want to
avoid those kinds of bigger words
because they don't necessarily add a lot
of value. Utilize. If you look it up, it just
means you use. Problematical just means
problem. Academia is another way to say
college. You want to use plain language
whenever you can because every once in a
while, they'll be a thought you can't
possibly express plainly and you want to
leave room in your sentences for that
more sophisticated idea. And to do so you
want to simplify everything else that
you can into very plain English. I
actually have heard a lot of people
coming up through grad school use the
word problematical and I just never
understood
why they would use such a demanding word. So, don't use flowery language when simple
language will do. Say it in plain English.
Contemplate. How would you say this word,
contemplate? How would you translate that?
I would say think. Commence. Is another
fancy way to say start. And, Terminate is
a fancy way to say end. Now you don't
have to do this in every single case but
in general, to be concise and to make to
make nice concise sentences, you want to use plain English. Let's say this one in
plain English. I was reflecting on my
position and have altered my perspective on
the matter. What's the person really
saying? I think they're saying, I changed
my mind. And that's how you want to
express yourself. And there's no way to
misunderstand a nice plainly worded
sentence. So use short sentences with as
few words as possible. You take-away
strategies are to shave the clutter like
Seinfeld and other people who really
work on compressing those sentences. And
use plain English whenever you can. You
take-away task here is to apply this
in conversations and Q&A in the next few
days and make a habit out of answering
with short concise sentences. In our next
lesson, we're going to look at how to
organize your thoughts clearly. I look
forward to seeing you then.